hello everybody my name is markiplier
and apparently I'm very wet so we're
back with don't starve in the Marga
Blair mod and if I seem a little tense
right now there's a reason for that I am
still wearing pants and I decided to
start recording this and I wasn't even
recording so I was just shouting into
the camera about how great this mod was
and they've done a lot to add stuff to
this game I didn't hit the record button
and my pants which aren't just pants or
jeans by the way and a little too tight
if I might add I can't take them off
because there's a window right there
everyone would be able to see me in my
pants Allah states and that wouldn't be
such a bad thing I've recorded in my
underwear before but unfortunately I may
or may not be wearing underwear so I
can't do anything and I'm wet and I'm a
little bit frustrated and it's a little
too hot going on here there's a weird
circle a life going on here I don't know
what this all is about oh boy oh I need
to make a campfire oh oh well everything
is wet I don't know how to escape the
wetness but right now oh I didn't even
talk about because I said it before into
nothingness when it wasn't recording
that there's been a lot out of do this
game there's been a new character that
I'm trying to get that I'm trying to get
to he's by the name of Wilfred Wharf -
and if I'm able to get into the monster
forum at night
I'm able to kill this guy by the name of
the hooded hero I'm unable to get a key
from him to go find the blacksmith safe
and then that will unlock the new
character but I have to leave in like 15
minutes here so if it doesn't happen
Oh uh-oh I've no idea I need to restart
because this is going wrong poor boy
okay welcome back everyone to don't
starve we got off on the wrong foot with
this episode so I just wanted to say I
apologize for doing what I did I did not
take my pants off so I'm just gonna talk
through this recording until the very
end okay thank you for Duke for adding
more to this game there's a lot of stuff
to be done I'm gonna go oh it crashed ah
okay we're back once again in this Sun
we're in the game ready to roll
work it up what what's about to die
don't talk about bout to die because I'm
not about to die right now I've got a
lot of game to cover and you're not
gonna die on me you son of a [ __ ] okay
now that that's over with now we can go
on a merry way and find out the rest of
this game so that we can get war stats
unlocked and you guys can see all the
cool stuff that's happening huh huh why
is everything still wide for signee
buxom where is tiny box em no where's
Jim what have you done with Jim oh my
god where's Tim Tim ah I need to turn
new game I can't do without Jim no no no
okay this time for real we're starting
off on a new foot we're gonna do great
we're gonna have lots of fun and we're
gonna find out all the cool stuff that's
involved in the newest update of the
Marga bar Montford Oh barb hello there
oh you're different now
gotta box him oh there you are my little
biscuit I don't think I've properly
updated the mod before but so I don't
even think
would have happened anyway but now
everything is gonna be hunky-dory and
I'm gonna have a great time
I am indeed too pro dickbag I know
hello Am I Oh boom I'm okay now
I'm all awake so woah alright Tim's
Chinese plushie wow that got a lot
beefier holy hell I'm awesome oh I got
my deep voice in there Oh Papa da ba Bou
sounds like a bass flapping away over
there yeah that's what my lyrical
softness and my voice sounds like at all
times
ba ba bunnies okay so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go gather up stuff and
hopefully at the end of the night I'll
be able to turn into the monster I'll be
able to get the key I'll be able to go
do the thing to find what I need to find
in order to complete this game it's
gonna be a lot of fun you guys are gonna
see it
and I just want to say I'm not
ungrateful what they've done I just
started off a weird note for this
episode I apologize in advance for my
outburst it was uncalled for and frankly
unprofessional you guys deserve better
than that you do you really do Oh how do
I turn it up oh god I forgot how to turn
the oh it's over there okay well I need
to turn that off because that consumes a
lot of my stuff that I need so I'm just
gonna I'm gonna take a little bit of a
breather here I'm gonna go do my things
quietly without yelling and screaming
and then I want to get back to you when
it is time to adventure further into
this mod be back in a little bit you
lovely lovelies here you want you little
plushie buddy oh there you go you're so
cute you make all my troubles go away
and I am so many troubles right now Oh
barely it's late right now oh that
that's good to know
hopefully I'll be able to do something
tonight hello my little Jackie double
boob
friends whatever you call what a fairy
based I wonder why Wilford likes him so
much wait a minute I don't think Wilford
knows anything about these guys maybe
I'll ask him when I'm finally him why am
i picking up so much poop
why why why is this a thing I'm doing it
seems like it's an important thing or
something or other maybe I don't know
well hello there you're a big old poop
oh oh I found it
I can't believe I found it that's that's
the locked blacksmith that's what I need
that's I need that oh my god it's right
here I need that I need that so badly to
be able to do this now if you couldn't
tell there's been a bit of a time change
I don't know how you'd be able to tell
but I actually left and I came back to
play the same game in holy crap it's
right there I feel a lot better by the
way I've calmed myself down I actually
still have pants on but you know that's
okay because I'm playing this fantastic
fantastic game that was made by a
fantastic dude thank you so much for
helping out and making this game it
really means a lot to me that people
have pigs game I hate that this game
started off or this episode started off
so hectically
I was just in a panic because I had no
time and actually I'm in a really good
move now because III just went and I
spoke with the egoraptor that's who I
was meeting I was meeting with egoraptor
cuz he's a really cool guy and like
we're a meeting for any specific reason
we're just meeting because we wanted to
hang out and talk and like we talked for
like an hour and a half and that guy III
fangirl about the game grumps a lot but
also because egoraptor is a really cool
guy and I
oh I can nothing go right when I'm
playing this game okay seems like it
still works please still be there yes
okay it is still there
we're still good we're still fine
everything is awesome everything is cool
oh when you're part of the team okay so
as I was saying I was just going down uh
cuz me and Igor after we uh we just were
able to sit down and talk and like I
really really he's such a cool guy to be
able to talk to and I've been a fan of
him forever I've watched his animations
for a long time and the best part about
being in the YouTube scene and being
able to meet all these cool people is it
these these really cool people and they
are just young people they're general
everyday people that you're able to meet
and hang out and have fun with like yeah
I I get this opportunity to meet these
really cool people and and that's one of
the best things about this and that this
you know a whole YouTube thing has been
able to lead me to is that I have been
able to meet these idols of mine like
these people that I've been a huge fan
of forever and get to know them and like
that special like that's special not
everyone would get to do that and he's
just generally one of the coolest guys
I've ever known so I love the game
grumps just because I love all of it
like Dani Ross berry and Suzy and Aaron
and I love all them just cuz they're
really cool people that make really cool
things and that's one of the things I
care about the most
oh okay
Oh what just happened
barking everything
I killed the hooded hero do you know
what that means but man they did a good
job this used to just be a different
thing he used to be a generica monster
from this but oh my goodness there's a
legit monster
okay so anyway
got this
insane episode I've ever seen
let's go oh my god I did blue hair guy
up there's been just the most
interesting experience to speaker whoa I
will lead you and your delicious meat oh
my god whoa all right then
I don't even know the thing to spend
vemos
over the place episode I've ever seen in
my life it's been the longest between
the beginning of it and the end of it to
record an episode I've ever taken and to
be honest I don't know what just
happened you tell me okay so anyway holy
crap
this has been amazing but yeah I what
was I even talking about I've been so
fortunate to be able to be here and do
all these things doesn't that guy
supposed to drop a key way no no wasn't
he supposed to drop a key Oh supposed to
get a key out of that I don't know what
happened but oh man
but either way is just like I get to
meet these cool people and I get to meet
these cool people who are honestly
inspirations of mine and it's an honor
it's like an honor to be able to do this
it's an honor to be able to have these
opportunities to do this and it's a it's
an honor because you guys are giving me
this opportunity to branch out and do
these cool things with these cool people
so you know just up I'm honored that
people make this stuff for me and that's
the weird thing about it all is that I'm
just a normal guy just like all these
other youtubers they're just normal guys
and they're either cool or [ __ ] and
I'm fortunate enough to only have met
the cool one so far and frankly all of
them look pretty cool but it's just like
uh I'm honored and I'm humbled and I
don't know why I deserve to have these
cool opportunities but I'm so thankful
that I do so just thank you from the
bottom of my heart for giving me the
opportunity to do this and have these
things and and like just experience all
of this it's
it's just pure and simple awesome so
from the bottom of my heart thank you
guys so much for making this stuff like
this and giving me the chance to meet
the cool people like Eagle Raptor in the
game grumps and everyone else that I met
on YouTube you know I just recently met
a beautiful like I met him in person
we've done videos before and people may
have his opinions on his videos and you
can like his videos or not like his
videos but I met the guy in person
he's a seriously cool guy like
legitimately he's a nice guy and some
people don't like my videos some people
think that my videos are scum of the
world
scum of the earth but hey that's fine
that's your opinion you can say whatever
you want about me you can say whatever
you want about my videos and it doesn't
matter to me but honestly I've gotten
the chance to meet these cool people and
I can never forget that you guys have
given me the opportunity to do that so I
don't know how this episode got from
doing all of that to doing all of this
to getting here I turned into the
monster and I could have sworn that the
hooded hero is supposed to get me a key
to do that
what is this think of a ring thing oh
yeah I don't know what a ring thing is
but what I don't know oh no where's Tim
oh it's not anybody oh god no not again
with this everything's gonna get wet
again and I'm not gonna be able to do
anything I like with this it's not gonna
help
not even a little better is that
actually helping I have no idea what do
you what I don't know we're tiny buxom
one I'm all over the place of this I
have no idea what I'm doing
oh well that's cool he's burned down
everything that's the whole everything's
on fire oh I was on fire for a little
bit there but either way I just wanted
to say thank you guys I'm gonna get back
to try to unlock that box because
everything has been going weird but just
thank you guys so much for being awesome
that's all that's Ava there we are
hey what are you doing eating another I
will murder your sake
oh no you've died aren't you supposed to
drop it now all my stuff is on fire God
now what are you supposed to give me a
key
I thought those a thing though is smoked
out and I'm not even a dog woof woof -
if it doesn't oh yeah I think actually
I'm done with this episode because I
have no idea what the hell happened to
cross is all I know is that I'm
SuperDuper grateful that people are
still making the stuff so please please
go check out this mod on the community
side of don't starve all you have to go
snooze go into your game click on
community hub and find a search
markiplier you should be able to find
it's awesome
pure and simple it is awesome if you're
a fan of me you'll be a fan of this so
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for everyone for making this thank you
for watching and thank you for watching
me since I've been on YouTube and thank
you all of the youtubers who are just
plain and simple awesome people so
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
the grouted take care of him
where's the black swear I'll kill him
he's been tormenting our blacksmith too
much I will murder your favor long
Oh Liam